because it evens you it's fair to say
you're quite lukewarm about this scheme
you know I mean the first thing to say
is it's absolutely a really important
issue reducing plastic waste improving
recycling rates and that's very clear
but I think well the the announcement of
the consultation does today is actually
it provides more questions than it does
answers there's still quite a lot of
unknowns about how the scheme would work
and for our members the biggest concern
really for the smallest stores is just
space as you saw in the pieces and start
the program these machines are not small
and the stores that would have to put
them in you know simply just don't have
space in many cases so you would want to
see presumably stores being compensated
for the space that these machines would
take up and also they're going to be
collecting plastic bottles at the back
of the store well that's that's one of
the one of the great unknowns about the
year the announcements a day so that the
machines that the big machines are
estimated cost up to 30,000 pounds each
which if you imagine you're a very small
business that's a lot of money that's
without upkeep and staff costs as well
and but the other option a manual scheme
where you just take the bottles and cans
and glass behind the till that provides
its own problem so quite genius hygiene
issues absolutely dirty bottles health
and safety issues queuing times in
stores and you know this is a business
that is predicated on getting people in
and out as quickly as they can in a
convenient way you know and helping them
shop without undue delay now in Germany
when this was introduced Aldi and Lidl
who obviously dominate the grocery
market over there basically installed
machines that only took back bottles
that had been bought in their stores
presumably if we get this system in the
UK you want to be able to have your
members have their bottles recycled
anywhere again this is one of the great
unknowns there's the systems across
Europe are different in the ways they
operate most of them are are the the big
machines though they're reversed only
machines but again those stores are are
typically bigger as you said the Aldi
and Lidl they are bigger stores and the
vast majority of our members are under
2,000 square feet which is less than the
size of a tennis court these are small
stores we're talking about and you know
one of the other unknowns is about like
you said how people will get back that
money is it on cash is it on a card is
it on some sort of almost like an oyster
card is it you know any number of
options that are still at play here so
you know we absolutely welcome the
consultation but as I said more
questions and answers
would you what would your members prefer
presumably cash well I think there are
there are associated costs with car
payment absolutely but I think there's
and as the the working group that's been
tasked with doing this for the last six
months looking at this and their report
came out today and they said well
actually more work needs to be done to
work out a proper solution that works
for everyone and we absolutely welcome
so where this system has been rolled out
elsewhere in Northern Europe what has
been the experience of small stores have
many of them gone bust well as I said
the nature of those stores is typically
they are the largest source generally in
in doll in Europe and these are systems
that have been in place for quite a long
time and one of the main things I look
at is the impact on recycling rates and
and spirits they vary there there will
be some areas where a recycling rates
have done quite well as sorry as where
it's been not as much but one of the big
differences between Northern Europe and
the UK the UK has a very well
established curbside collection scheme
and what we're not sure about and
another question about the scheme is the
impact they will have on curbside
because all we don't want to do is
people that are would otherwise recycle
normally though they wouldn't have to
walk past the recycling box right
outside their home to then go and
getting their car and recycle at a at a
store so that's another one of the
questions it really needs answering in
the consultation now let's see the
Scottish Government's further down the
road in this respect how you satisfied
with things shaping north of the border
well I think that raises its own issues
because if the scheme in England is any
different in the scheme in Scotland and
that could potentially cause problems
around the border and similarly if there
are plans in Wales and that would cause
issues the working group that I spoke
about just now they said that they would
be very keen for a scheme to work across
the UK and when we do get to a scheme
that is workable and that doesn't cause
undue harm to retailers and that there
helps to increase recycling rates we
would expect a scheme like that to be
introduced across the UK all right Chris
noise from the association of
convenience stores good to see it thanks
is your name